we are waiting on people to show up
assuming anybody actually shows up
hopefully people do there we go we got
people showing up you know we six
everybody a minute or two but then
people start showing up oh man what's
going on guys what is up man it always
baffles me all these comments that just
come rolling in but um can i cover more
Miles Morales yes I need to I definitely
need to anyway guys so um so yeah we're
doing a quick little Q&A here um nothing
be kind of fun to talk to you guys for a
little it's always kind of interesting
to you because it's like hey guys we're
gonna do a quick little Q&A and then it
turns in like an hour
so it gets kind of weird but I love
talking to you guys so that's that's
always fun to me which by the way can we
get some likes in this video um okay so
so we're going to whatever what legacy
is here in a second
because I know there's a lot of people
out there who don't know what it is and
so we're gonna run over legacy here a
little bit but do I like cake yes I do
if you don't like cake there's something
wrong with you that's that's my answer
um let's see uh no way Jose
lot of comments are spanning from my
favorite youtuber yeah what's up how's
it going who will win
hooker Thor the Incredible Hulk I'm
pretty sure would be Thor the only
exception would be the hammer so long as
I guess Thor without the hammer would
lose Thor what the hammer would probably
win where's the best place to buy comics
it depends on how you want to read them
I read mine digitally nine times out of
ten every once in a while I'll buy a
physical comic you know if the if the
scenario is so inclined so now my good
but I usually get mine on comiXology so
kind of Ecology you can actually go
there and curate your own list so you
can be like okay there's only like I
only care about Batman Superman you know
and I guess detective it actually called
me because they basically go with them
and then like you know spider-man and
something else can you cover Red Hood
and The Outlaws Thomas Holmes asked that
question with a $10 donation Thank You
Thomas
let me actually I told her well I cover
a Red Hood of the outlaws yes I cover
the first volume I cover the first one I
should go back I should probably go back
and cover him again to be honest um yeah
I should definitely go back and do those
um I think let's see volume 2 just ended
didn't it I think it did I'm not a hum
person sure if it did I need to cover it
but uh anyway um cloak and dagger info
bed I'll probably do it once we get
closer to the start of the show but no
until then I've always just kind of you
know hey Rob you're the best thing
coming out of DC rebirth are you going
to do more superior spider-man Jose
asked that question with a $5 relation
Thank You Jose
um yeah superior spider-man is every
Monday and we're going to do that until
we're done which means we're going to
we're going to do that until we get
caught up with spider-man so we're
literally going to run all the way up to
clone conspiracy then we're going to
stop and then we're going to jump into
Thor so we're going to start with like
the Ragnarok storyline and then we're
going to jump into J michael Straczynski
Thor when he resurrected it when he
brought him back so um let's see uh what
we're trying to get so far um what do I
think of Titans rebirth I love Titans
rebirth I feel like they're gonna get
ready to go into a whole great big huge
thing about about Donna Troy I think
we're kind of like redo version again
that seems to be the case that seems to
be par for the course that whatever she
shows up any kind of a reboot or
relaunch they basically go through her
origin again like we saw that with
Infinite Crisis it was the return of
Donna Troy and they basically ran
through her origin again so that one
responds they did that just tell me well
I hope you're having a good day thank
you mod key
moppy what's up thank you moppy um yeah
mopey is one of the guys really the guy
that kind of runs the whole discord
thing
so we keeps all that in order I want to
jump into home school I don't want to
jump into rebirth especially Batman
where should I start literally Batman
rebirth just start with Batman rebirth
vol 1 start with type of college vol 1
and that's all you need
you really need to know anything else
besides that that's one of the great
things is that it's really good
jumping-off point okay so let's talk
about more of a legacy for a second I
think we have as many people in here is
we're going to get I don't know if the
number is going to grow any more but um
let's talk about Marvel legacy so if
those you guys I don't know Marvel did
all-new all-different marvel they got
all kinds of flack for what you guys are
seeing right now all the backlash from
all-new all-different marvel is
basically what happened to DC with new
52 Marvel is getting a lot of flack
because they changed a lot of things got
rid of a lot of the established heroes
replace established heroes with with new
heroes and because of that people are
kind of going kind of going crazy what
there's a new model of Marvel heroes
game babies just spamming the hell out
of me with with with with stuff let's
see the x-men here always always
political but they used allegories is
Marvel going full social story that's
what the reason that's one of things
were answering here with with legacy
we'll get to that here in a second where
do you get your background music from
your videos epidemics sound can you
cover American Gods graphic novel I have
no oh that's coming out of aftermath
isn't it coming out of after any that
were actually looking at that I
remembered is this writing and I'm going
to say more I don't think that's right
respond back Letta but I know what
you're talking about and I will probably
cover that at some point when but I'm
not make time for that did you cover
Flash Thompson has been a space night or
how he wants a bit of Soviet know Vinnie
and I try not to cross over on each
other whenever we're doing content and
Benny was focusing pretty heavily on
venom like like agent venom and then
venom space Knight because it's all one
cohesive story going into venom
homecoming with all-new all-different
marbles so I'm going to wait till he
finishes and then I'll go in jump into
it
have you ever played the ultimate
spider-man video game
is the best thing coming out of the
alternate universe November playing
ultra spider-man video game conveying
awesome although got us about your
backlash for there were whole con words
that apply binya rob of course i win
why wouldn't i win and lots of it like
the Rob core wins why is been calling me
alright we're going to put our skype on
Do Not Disturb anyway so um so bumper
got a little backlash for for for under
all different Marvel and so because of
that basically what they're doing is
we're doing they're doing secret Empire
which goes into generations which looks
like a one-shot or something and then
Marvel legacy how do you how do I kill
score well that's what does they know
that's I give me a later time plus
Wednesdays how to kill the lactis so and
then after that it'll be how to kill the
guardians of the galaxy and then maybe
we'll do squirrel
but anyway so so Marvel legacy is
basically Marvel's DC rebirth um you
know I'm kind of on the fence about it
but I'm kind of looking forward to it
I'm not a sleepwalker oh can I cover
sleepwalker I thought dr. Bauer's office
hours it thought I asked if I was a
sleepwalker I have no idea what
sleepwalker is I've never heard that
before
anyway Marvel legacy is basically Marvel
DC rebirth and it's kind of interesting
because I feel like with Marvel I didn't
know how much I loved the way things
were before Secret Wars until they
weren't like that anymore he was gonna
you don't know what you have until it's
gone I was the first one to say I'd ever
say like we need changes like things
need to change store easy to change we
need characters need to change we do to
a degree I just kind of feel like a lot
of the changes we've gotten isn't
necessarily the best thing like I love
Jane Foster for I love the idea of x-23
being Wolverine I love riri Williams
Sam Wilson Captain America is
interesting and so far that it fits into
what you know Nick Spencer is doing in
terms of leading up to Secret Wars and
stuff like that um but for me the
biggest thing the biggest issue that
I've really had with all-new
all-different marvel is that the
Fantastic Four just aren't there and I
feel like with the Fantastic Four being
gone
it just lacks something you know it's
like a word on the edge of your mouth or
you know you know like a word on the tip
of your tongue or like a thought on the
ledge of your head it's just that's the
thing is something that you just can't
scratch the itch you can't scratch some
you can't quite put your finger on it's
just not right something's just a little
off and so hopefully the Fantastic Four
will come back and if they do I think
that would really signal to be getting
you know of these is Marvel's rebirth so
as we bomb a legacy really beginning to
take off but anyway so back into the
questions I don't wanna leave you guys
hanging Wendy more Swan stories yes we
do will do s'more do s'more Swan again
um a lot of the in D Day is on Tuesdays
and so we really have like Valiant
Comics which is a mainstay and there's
just kind of picking and choosing what I
want to do after that and so I try to
keep it like one shots that way I'm not
really the way I'm not I don't have
conflicting series because one of the
issues is running too many series of
ones and it'll throw people off but
anyway um do you expect a normal legacy
to have the same impact as rebirth I
think so
just because of all this because it's so
fresh and all the backlash that they've
gotten it would be like if DC launched
rebirth two years after the new 52 it
would have been like okay but the other
half of this is that only well different
Marvel you know have them hasn't really
had time to settle the dust hasn't
really really settled yet for a lot of
characters a lot of stories we're just
now getting into vol 2 or vol 3 so we're
just now approaching the 25 comic mark
and so because of that it really hasn't
been a lot of chance to establish
all-new all-different marvel in terms of
what it could be but in terms of all the
backlash and the fact that it's so fresh
I can see it having something something
near the similar impact of DC rebirth
but um let's see a century or Hyperion
century I'm pretty sure almost close to
a billion yeah we are close we're like
thirty thousand subs away a 25 thousand
I think actually it is really exciting
like fingers crossed it's really really
exciting thoughts on secret Empire
number zero you will find out this week
I loved a secret Empire number zero I
but it comes out on Thursday I think
I'll have my thing put up in front of me
but um leaked nudes if I had a million a
second you guys don't want to see me
naked I don't like seeing or something
um can you do spider-man scrapers like
Ravens last time um I don't know I mean
right now the spider-man stuff is really
basically everything that goes up to and
include spider-verse so we'll do stuff
like grim hunt you know and like the
Book of Ezekiel different things like
that all in preparation for spider-verse
but krebs last hunt will probably be
later on down the line to be honest um
will you cover a Thanos comic aha it's
funny that you ask that um let me let me
give you guys an inkling of things to
come can I don't know if I could turn my
camera around um I don't know if I can
look like it to do that oh yeah I can't
I can't I can't
all right sugars not sugars up so I
arranged all my stuff I have all these
videos planned out everything chickens
watching it up all right
oh sorry I have my eye on my cover on
the back okay so I had uh here we go um
maybe possibly alright uh there we go
you guys can kind of see that maybe it's
focusing in all right so um
hopefully do a little bit better but
anyway um so basically what it is is uh
that is uh yeah Wharf King's realm of
Kings all that stuff um
okay it's not quite zooming in the way
that I'd like it to so in any event um
what I was trying to show you guys is
that with regards to that that question
about Thanos so next year infinity war
comes out yes that type infinity war
comes out and so to celebrate infinity
war beginning the weekend or the week
though that movie comes out we're
covering everything
fans related so here is the stuff that
we're going to do you guys are you guys
ready you guys want me to tell you
exactly what we're going to cover
because when we tell you everything that
we're going to cover in terms of all
that stuff here's what we're going to
cover here's what we're going to do
alright so ah we have the origin of
Thanos
which is basically Thanos Frazee who we
got a question what do you think about
the cloak and dagger TV series trailer
um it'll be interesting it's a very
different take on cloak and dagger it's
very much designed for like teenagers
clueless design for teenage kids um it
doesn't really resonate with me too much
but you know again it might be really
really good so you know I have no idea
but anyway um so we're going with the
origin of Thanos
all right they were going with Thanos
versus Iron Man that's his first
appearance then we're going with Thanos
and the Cosmic Cube then Thanos first
death followed by his return the wrath
of Thanos which is where he tries to
capture the Cosmic Cube again actually
no I think it's winning first when we
first learn about the Infinity stones um
and then his second death and then the
return of Thanos which is the preload -
in famous quest none paddles quest then
Infinity Gauntlet then the Infinity
Gauntlet aftermath then infinity were
infinity Crusade Thanos cosmic powers
which is where he decides to fight all
the most powerful cosmic beings in the
Marvel Universe search me why I have no
idea and fairness Redemption
annihilation conquest because we already
covered annihilation then row of Kings
realm of kings
a god up there which is a really good
story status annual fairness revelation
famous versus the Hulk which is a really
cool story um and then it is just a ton
of stuff like the rest of the infinity
stuff and fitting the relativity entity
and finale the Fed is imperative and
then it's all Hickman's of hundreds of
New Avengers including infinity so we
get to see Thanos fight black belt and
smash his face into the ground so uh
yeah like it is it's gonna be big but my
goal because that's about 79 different
videos right there my goal is to
basically have that start and then wrap
all the way around to win Turman and
failure war part 2 comes out so it's a
year's worth of animus stuff and it's
going to be every Monday when I do that
so that's the idea is to finish off
Spider Man and then Gemina Thor finish
Thor and then go into Thanos so um I
have not seen 13 reasons why people keep
telling me it's good but I have not seen
that yet oh let's see baby Darkseid is
weird
Kevin comment no idea Capt'n common is
Punisher max notice you versus you um
Batman earth 1 those are kind of like
one shots that I might mingle in every
once in a while but no idea if I'm gonna
be able to pull that off got so many
questions coming in the real Hulk return
that's supposed to happen at Marvel
legacy Bruce Banner was supposed to go
back to being the incredible um oh wow
we got a couple real Cooper thank you so
much will Cooper Aunt May heard of
Galactus versus row brick or Hulk Herald
of Galactus who would win if I were
joking I would say on May Herald of
Galactus hands down there literally is
insane in seriousness is incredible
that's not even up for debate that's not
have any question it's crazy for
multiple legacy will there be all teams
coming back ok so that's the idea is
that old teams all superheroes they're
all going to make the return hopefully
it's actually that way hopefully that's
that's actually the case um I don't know
if it will be or not but that seems to
be how it's being built but then again
all-new all-different marvel was
effectively build as a reboot and it was
so Brett's gotta have to find out I just
kinda have to wait to see what happens I
had no idea but anyway um let's see uh
okay there's more questions cool um
let's see ah can I come ultimate
spider-man I'm ready to have Benny's
done to cover that again but try not to
step on each other's toes when it comes
to content so you love this journal I
appreciate that I'm glad you I'm glad
you dig this channel what we get 606
Logan I have no idea Scripture question
what was your question I'm sorry um
let's see uh who will win Wolverine vs.
spider-man um man it's a good question I
probably say Wolverine just because in
stories werewolves on kill the Marvel
Universe
he killed spider-man so I would say
probably probably Wolverine if for no
other reason than that I love your
channel who would win between fan oohs
with Infinity Gauntlet and dark side
with the anti-life equation battles with
the Infinity Gauntlet I think because
he's basically godhood he has the
supreme gun but that begs the question
if like Santa or if I Darkseid met the
spectre with the anti-life equation
could he been the spectre to his will
and I mean Specter entity not Specter as
as a Jim Corrigan like the actual
Specter entity I don't know I have no
idea Bob Harvey safe analyst with the
Infinity Gauntlet off the top my head do
it evil laugh no that's not a very good
evil laugh
do I think Marvel will lower their
prices no I do not think that will
happen I think mother would keep the
prices high
um do I prefer pancakes or waffles
waffles if I have to choose between
pancakes and waffles as waffles man good
God ask me that crazy question
am I going to finish Tom King's vision I
would like to UM that may be one that we
do just kind of like a one-off day or
something like that
because we have three days out of the
week that we cover all-new all-different
marvel or DC rebirth and I try to do two
videos a day so maybe one of them might
just be like a one-off I might pick like
that and like another day and just throw
it in there something along those lines
I don't know let's see
I feel like this iPad is not very
effective for large streaming on YouTube
it could definitely be more effective
do I read a straw city no I've heard of
it but I've never actually read it
let's see ah a cloak-and-dagger video
maybe I'm not I mean I thought would you
like an Origin or stuff like that when
it comes out but um I don't know I don't
think how to really see myself doing a
cloak-and-dagger video per se do you
think like the butcher's will get his
own solo series no but it'd be
interesting the closest we ever got to a
solo series from Franklin Richards was
powered hack and so I don't know I mean
but the question would be like what
would he do like what would his story be
about well we got we kind of got like a
fantastic first two but I don't know if
I mean I think Franklin is better when
he's like it hit was Fantastic Four were
like he serves a distinct purpose he
serves a particular role and that's it
but I don't know I mean it may be that
he turns into sending the ends up having
an interesting solo series I have I had
no idea
Carol Danvers or Wonder Woman Wonder
Woman definitely what are you going to
cover the the maker and Hickman's
Ultimates run
that's a good question I've never really
given it any thought before um I don't
know I have no idea I was gonna dress
miss for a while but I just sort of do
any spider-man and so I don't I don't
know again with my schedule the issue
that I would have is trying to do too
much anyone just confuse the heck out of
people when we can get away with it I
have no idea we might be able to pull it
off but anyway I just plain Steve Farhad
but well thanks just play Steve I
appreciate it um let's see
Krypton so here's about the sci-fi
series yeah I'm looking forward to that
like I'm actually pretty pretty hyped
about that um I'm pretty excited about
it like I think it'll be pretty solid
the release will be interesting but it's
on Syfy so I've always gotten a lot
better recently in terms of the content
they produce so but originals are not
bad so I mean kind of curious to see
what they do with it unless they'll get
a whole lot of leeway just because it's
Krypton I mean this is my most symbolic
planet is a history of fiction so I have
a hard time believing that you know they
get a hold on leeway
but super Campari kind of a day ending
week did I hear about it no I didn't
hear about it no I didn't hear anything
about it um let's see do I think Shazam
will get a rebirth comic I hope so
because he's been noticeably absent and
I'm really hoping he shows up because
enough enough of what I understand from
what I've been hearing he's got a big
world of play in DC rebirth and that's
one reason why he's just been on the
back burner
it's because his return is supposed to
be like a huge thing so I have no idea
but um yeah I'm kind of hoping that it
turns into something pretty pretty big I
mean there's really pretty awesome
anyway um whatever thing about Teen
Titans rebirth I love it I love Damian
Wayne having his own Teen Titans team I
think is pretty pretty solid it was
pretty interesting a low-key video well
I thought about doing a low-key video
but because of the fact that we're going
to be covering everything from male thor
ragnarok going forward all the
interesting things that you guys care
about for Loki will be covered during
that so like Loki being a chick stuff
like that all that is going to come out
of what in the world all that's going to
come out of our videos on Thor so um
thoughts of group multiple rebirth by
miracle man thoughts of normal political
miracle man I know you mean like a
miracle man story from like moral legacy
is that what you're asking because they
didn't they did miracle name with all in
all different normal and I didn't read
it I didn't care anything about it so
let's see can you cover spot him into
probably I may cover the original Spider
Men just we all have just to having time
for spider-man 2 so how do I like the
Legion TV series I loved of the Legion
TV series I thought it was amazing it
was one of my favorite definitely my
favorite shows especially for a
miniseries I think that like having an 8
or 9 episodes was the perfect length
anything longer than that and people
were just started dropping off because
it would have become too complicated
even the direction that they were going
in all of their probably could have done
like 6 or 7 and they would have kept a
strong audience base but it was fine I
mean for what it was I'd loved it so
will you cover any Doctor Doom stories
anytime soon and what is my favorite do
story love my channel by the way thank
you fealty do by fall
you do but that's an awesome name thank
you for doing that I'd like to believe
but I thought you do bad they're just
like run around and just never do what
it's supposed to do and just like walk
against was I'm wrecking the walls and
stuff like that just like dirt there's
like BL Derby and everything um my
favorite dr. Doom's story is definitely
books of doom
that's definitely best those guys who
don't know books of doom is the Ed
Brubaker story where he basically ran
over dr. Doom's origin like it was a
total relaunch of his origin which I
covered that I have that here on my chin
so there was a really really good story
um in terms of covering more doctor do
stories right now infamous Ironman is
talking about the best we're going to
get in terms of interesting stories with
him there is do more and I do want to
cover do more what he invades Wakanda
and Black Panthers first to render all
the vibranium on the planet Earth
completely inert like that is something
that I'm really wanting to do like
that's that's something that I thought
was pretty solid there would be a good
place to start to get into Thor Jason
Aaron Scott butcher that's the best
place to start if you're interested in
Thor right now it all goes back to God
butcher that's basically the beginning
of the arc they're ready to begin about
this it all comes goes goes into God
butchers are just anything that says
Thor and says Jason Aaron read that and
then you'll be fine so grab a reading
order though while you were out there
crushing crisis has a really really good
reading order that's the one that I use
for the Incredible Hulk and that's the
one I'll be using for fur and then
there's also like kind of a Carol and
there's a few others but prior
compression crisis has the most in-depth
reading order I think um Maxwell Lord
versus taskmaster who would win uh I'm
probably Maxwell Lord just because of
the faculty can influence the minds of
people
so the Rob core versus captain here at
the rock for man Devin yes always when
you guys are all winners in my okay no
was there was the I think a good way I
mean captain carrot school but at the
end of the day he's a super rabbit he's
a super buddy but he's not he's not that
might be the best way to get more
culturally diverse characters and the
graphic novel comics industry to give
them good stories and don't shoot when
they man give like original characters
those throws were screwed like replace
existing characters
Sam Wilson taking over the role of
Captain America just made sense because
he'd been the sidekick of Steve Rogers
for decades so I mean it's only he was
just a new creation in the realm of a
secret Empire is amazing doesn't like
he's just a new creation in the realm of
Marvel Comics
you know they just kind of threw him in
there Ruby Williams could have used a
little more backstory before she became
Iron Man she could've been fleshed out a
little bit more I think it would have
been would have been interesting to see
her with her own solo series where she
was an Iron Man but working up to that
point as opposed to having you know to
like having like 12 issues of invincible
Iron Man and then she takes over the
role um it was a little rush it was a
little fast it's not bad like people let
people to tell you it's the worst thing
ever it's not that bad but you know it
was a little it was a little rushed I
think that's our mother rebirth going
back to original numbering that's going
to throw people off I think and the
reason why is because of this DC got
away with it because it was Action
Comics and detective it was only two
books that were going back to the
original numbering no so it was very
easy to kind of go with that it's these
two books the only ones with their
original number nothing you just pick up
with that plus the banner on the front
that says you know DC we were not going
back to the original numbering with like
a lot of their books is an issue
especially because of the fact they
remembered them so many times already
that's one of the reasons why if you go
and look at like certain Fantastic Four
comics you let's say like issue number
500 14/2 or something like that none of
it says that but it will say five 14/2
because it means overall does the 514
issue but it's the second issue in the
current like art per the current run or
something like that go back to the
original numbering is going to throw
people off I think it might kind of
confuse people a little bit honestly if
I were them I would have just said one
last time we're remembering and then
we're done people will get past the
renumber who don't care about the
renumber if the stories are good because
we're going to be like with the stories
are great who cares it as renumber a few
people will be vocal but most people
just won't care if you can have a kind
of book a kind of a character or have a
character from another book movie game
etc to into the Marvel Universe who I
choose and why um who that's a good one
um probably Ellie for the Last of Us to
be honest because she was such a great
dynamic character and then I would have
her the only one I'd ever become maybe
like an agent of shield or something
like that it'll be cool to kind of read
her off doing her own thing you know
being a SHIELD agent going on missions
or something like that I have no idea um
let's see Ghost Rider versus Etrigan I
don't know enough about that you're
going to make that argument so I have no
idea um we are almost 1 million we can
take most of the Supergirl yeah we can
just by sheer numbers we can just beat
the hell out of most of the superheroes
best DC we both comics ooh Batman
Superman protective action to me those
are just the four best right off the bat
Greg reckless Wonder Woman is amazing it
is so good um let's see definitely uh
definitely um I think I like Justice
League I really dig that but I feel like
I'm in the minority of people who like
Justice League I feel like most people
are just like that's boring yourself and
they don't care
Trinity is definitely really good um and
then there's some really strong titles
like Deathstroke's pretty strong Red
Hood and The Outlaws is really strong
super Sons was really really Charlotte
we're only three issues in so it's way
too early to gauge whether or not it'll
be a good consistent story I think it
will but Teen Titans I think is kind of
disappointing that John Barry Meyers
left acting like two issues because his
art is amazing but uh but yeah just off
top my head those are some pretty solid
ones what do you think of scarecrow with
the yellow power line yellow lantern I
think it makes sense
literally scarecrow is just a guy who
feeds on fear and use those for your
against people like it makes perfectly
good sense thoughts I'd never getting
cancelled it was so good oh I know I
think it's such a so weird that they
would just cancel it like that like I
understand I don't know if it was low
sales I mean I don't know why but like I
don't know why they canceled I loved it
I absolutely loved
I'd love to know I don't know why they
got rid of it was so disappointing you
know they killed off Richard rather than
they're cancelling the book and I don't
understand why they're doing that it's
it's weird um let's see uh okay would
you like to see the concept of the third
core in the main mobile universe yes I
loved the Thor core that was so cool
seeing basically like a police force it
was amazing I really really dug it and I
would love to see that make a return um
let's see Galactus from the empire from
all versus the Empire from start with
Galactus I mean and just because the
member of force users on the side of the
Empire are just too small and Galactus
is just too powerful matter manipulation
on the atomic scale no they don't stand
a chance against Galactus it's just you
know that's just not going to happen
but um let's see uh how did I kill
Vinnie he was getting him away um let's
see ah hard for Young Justice season
three I never really watched Young
Justice it was never really my thing so
I'm gonna go back and check it out but I
was it was never really my thing
thoughts I'm so glad canceling I don't
know so it was canceled but Badgett
shows you how little I was keeping up
with it I was not reading sulk it was
not my thing I was not remotely
interested in that plus I was looking at
like I thought about covering it and I
was looking up the reviews and I went to
Goodreads and and it was getting like
miracle reviews the best people were
just like here's the thing is a comic
that exists out there so am I going to
do spider-man 29 or the Twitter on
universe I would love to cover the 2099
universe I would absolutely love to
cover that but again it's just a matter
of finding time now that would thrill me
to cover that because there's so much
cool stuff and yet Punisher 2099 and so
on then I'd love to cover I think dr.
doing isn't 2099 isn't it
I would love to cover all that but okay
Doctor Doom versus Batman both have
unlimited prep obviously unbiased Doctor
Doom doctor nearby margin and I'm saying
that just because Batman fans will be
like Batman like I'm even the biggest
fan of Doctor Doom I'm just saying dr.
doom just because the Batman
fans are going to be like because Batman
would win like ice famine he always won
um Robin my reading renew your vows no
that's that's one of the stories I
intended to read and trade I didn't
intend to read it issue by issue that's
one of the biggest issues that I've had
with Marvel there's a lot of the comics
I'm not reading issue by issue there's a
few old man Logan
Thor stuff like that but mostly I'm just
waiting to the train to come out and
then I read it then just because it's
six months between the start of the
story and the end of the story and I
forget what happened by the time the
beginning you know that time the
beginning or the ending comes around so
I just wait until the trade comes out um
let's see uh have like a served writing
comics yes I thought about writing a
comic the Batman got the Blue Lantern
ring but not allows just I don't I don't
know I mean after meeting Hickman like
hey it was kind of kind of inspired me
to want to write a comic but I feel like
it would cut off more like a story than
a comic like a book and I'm a lot of
love that would be effective in writing
comics but um let's see oh I think of
the past lives arc of old man Logan I
don't think oh yeah yeah no that's cool
the art doesn't really sympathy but I'm
so used to Honduras or antinos or that
it's it's tough to accept anything other
than him um but you know I am mmm
I'm a drawing idea I just kind of wish
it however Sorrentino was there let's
see are you reading captain Adam you
should if I'm not reading it but I'm
sorry if you're saying it's good I'll
check it out then if you're singing this
solid then yeah I'll definitely take a
look at it let's see do you think they
should hire Michael I write to the
villain to fight Luke Asia next season I
think Michaels well I should have been
back Panther but I mean his acting isn't
necessarily the greatest but they could
work on that I mean they could work that
out but the guy's got the physical
prowess he's in great shape he's like a
multi level martial artist like he's
he's legit I definitely would have
picked him so um it's a rather graphic
novel yeah and I wish I could but
animals I'd be very solid writing about
man graphic
i problem where he got a Blue Lantern
Reno if I were going to write a Batman
original graphic novel hard right one
where he got the Blue Lantern ring
because I feel like it would turn
everything on his head right like people
say what Batman inspires fear so on and
so forth but if Gotham City gets that
bad people will look to Batman for hope
and I feel like because of that he would
be the perfect candidate for a blue
legend ring and basically become a
symbol of hope in the realm of Gotham
City but um where I think of DC super
son so far and which one of the two is
on here that Jonathan Kent is my
favorite and I love super son so far the
fact that one of the episodes woke up
with with Argus I just one of the
characters with I'm sorry both quarters
woke up and they had a sleepover that's
cool like they're just looking over each
others house like that's just fun
because that's so what I used to do as a
kid you know you have sleepovers stuff
like that robberies channel still going
would you ever reload that Silver Surfer
video there that's how I discovered my
channel to look into the darkness and
choose the light okay so I don't know
what happened in that video I think I
deleted it but that is a monologue from
the Silver Surfer story and I'm going to
say was the war of kings or it was like
anihilation conquest or something like
that I don't remember but it was a
server sort of tie into an existing
story but it wasn't really really cool
like it was a really really cool
monologue so that's Hank rivers Iron Man
I love the w Doom I heard Marvel makes
this version of Maine State well it's
only supposed to be a limited series
it's are supposed to be only supposed to
be nine issues along but I do love
infamous Ironman like I do love this
version of Iron Man it's pretty solid in
my book um let's see uh what's my beef
up in your homeland it's all part of the
show guys it's all part of the on
running gag um let's see do I prefer
Damian or Superboy prone a super or I'm
definitely just I love his character
assume you're talking about characters
yeah
Damian Wayne would not stand a chance
against Superboy brown but I really love
the characters so that was always fun
anyway guys I need to go ahead and get
laundry goin and I need to get some
sleep I'm exhausted so I'm gonna go
ahead and bounce off here but thanks for
coming out guys just a really quick you
know thirty seven minute QA nothing too
super like you're anything but it's want
to talk to you guys for a little while
those are some questions that you all
might have had out there and you know
rad pearl and
yeah I'll cut you guys a piece